Texas agency is threatening to fire
employees if they wear clothing that is
not consistent with their birth
genitalia this is I mean listen
we we've started to suspect that the
transphobic movement of the right and
meshed with the magarite is really
overplaying its hand with the anti-woke
stuff the polling suggests that the
country is far more woke than these
anti-worksters want to pretend it
doesn't seem like this is a way to win
elections and yet they will not stop
this is the latest it's probably illegal
but we will get to that in a moment Vice
news reports Texas agency threatens to
fire people who don't dress quote
consistent with their biological gender
the internal Department memo is just the
latest attempt by state officials in
Texas to crack down on trans and gender
non-conforming people this is the Texas
Department of Agriculture their mission
is to promote production agriculture
consumer protection Economic Development
and healthy living and apparently the
gender binary rights Vice news this is a
memo distributed last week saying you
are required to dress in a manner quote
consistent with your biological gender
the memo obviously aimed at trans and
non-gen gender non-conforming employees
says if you repeatedly dress the wrong
way there will be quote corrective
action
up to and including being fired
think about that
this is and the article says the latest
attempt by state officials to crack down
on trans people
let's discuss a couple of aspects of
this first of all could this possibly be
legal my opinion which is not my legal
opinion but that of legal experts who
whose opinions I've read is that it is
not legal now anytime we say is this
legal and there isn't precedent we're
all just speculating it's very important
to understand that if it's not already
written into the law and if there is no
precedent all we have is a speculation
where we try to apply whatever law does
exist to the facts of the case in this
situation could you fire people or even
just mandate that they dress consistent
with their biological gender could it
possibly be legal the best legal
assessments I've seen suggest almost
certainly not you've got Title VII of
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 which
prohibits employer discrimination
employment discrimination I think we
would say on the basis of sex now that
that includes Banning discrimination
against people who don't conform to
traditional gender Norms so this means
as an employer you wouldn't be allowed
to discriminate against employees based
on their gender identity nor their
gender expression and certainly the way
you dress is part of your gender
expression we also have a June 2020
a Supreme Court ruling in Bostic V
Clayton County which specifically found
title VII's protections against sex
discrimination do extend to sexual
orientation as well as gender identity
and so that ruling if we understand it
uh establishes that firing someone on
the basis of gender identity or sexual
orientation orientation would be illegal
now some of the Defenders of this policy
will say you're allowed to identify as
energy any gender you want but you've
got to dress a certain way so they would
say this isn't a violation of any law
because if you are a biological male
you're allowed to identify as a woman
you're just not allowed to wear dresses
or skirts or high heels or I guess
whatever else in 2023 in Texas is
determined to be consistent with with
gender Norms realistically
I believe that courts would find apparel
is an expression of that gender identity
makeup is an expression of gender
identity and therefore it would be
protected assuming it is not obscene
that's the other aspect of this that
sometimes the transphobes will go to
they'll say well
obscenity isn't protected well it's
going to be very difficult to argue that
a biological male wearing a dress to
think of the prototypical example is in
any way obscene it would be very
difficult to make that case legally so
that is the legal question I think based
on everything I've read almost certainly
would be illegal then there is the
question of whether politically they are
overplaying their hand and I believe
there the answer is yes when you
actually ask people their views on has
there was recently a very good poll
which asks people questions like for
example
have we done when it comes to
protecting uh and recognizing the
circumstances of trans people and their
concerns have we done enough the right
amount or not enough
the polling comes down on thinking that
we have done about the right amount or
not enough when it comes to protecting
trans people that's the woke view on
that issue and so the polling suggests
that their hand is being overplayed and
then the third aspect I guess I will
mention is
who cares about this stuff to the degree
that you actually are bothered and think
about it I I tweeted about this earlier
you know this is a true story yesterday
I was out working at a cafe I was doing
research for today's show I'm sitting
there on my laptop and all of a sudden A
Guy Walks By Me wearing high heels
wearing a men's suit a traditional men's
haircut everything if you've got a men's
shoulder bag
and high heels and I looked over and I
really looked over and I said to myself
wait a second
I should really double check one of
these sources I'm looking at and I went
back to my business and it had no impact
on me whatsoever if I had been there
with my baby daughter I wouldn't have
been at all concerned that a guy walked
by in high heels
how is it that people have even
convinced themselves that this is a
significant issue in their lives just
let people do what they want to do
there's no crime there's no obscenity
there's no any of it so I think the
Texas Department of Agriculture
overplaying their hand politically
probably against the law and also just
shows you must not have much going on in
your life if this is something that
you're concerned with uh President Joe
Biden has given his first speech since
announcing that he will be running for
re-election in 2024. now failed former
president Donald Trump trump was trunk
Trump or Trump was massively triggered
by Joe Biden's announcement we'll get to
that later let's first start with a
speech given by Joe Biden now you all
know Joe Biden's not my favorite
I'm not like a Joe Biden you know
cheerleader but he seems significantly
energized by this announcement he spoke
yesterday at North America's Building
Trades Union legislative conference his
first speech since announcing the 2024
campaign
standing ovations energy going after the
magats let's take a listen
I mean it it's wrong it's simply wrong
if it is lesser they should think I was
making it up
and meanwhile guess what my mega
Republican friends of Congress are up to
the Speaker of the House went to Wall
Street
last week suppose used cuts and
important programs cut all discretionary
spawning by 22 percent
including ones I just named
programs
millions of working and middle class
Americans count on
at the same time he and his Maggie
Republican colleagues are pushing some
tax giveaways for the wealthiest
Americans and biggest corporations
they'd rather see kids and seniors
struggle to eat what they need
people on Medicaid lose their health
care veterans lose access to doctors
visits and that's part of it by the way
not a joke
then cut subsidies to Big Oil that made
200 billion dollars
and big Pharma
the wealthiest Corporal corporations
and I'm talking about raising the tiger
just stop the subsidies
same old trickle-down dressed up in Maga
clothing
worse all right so certainly we're
grading a little bit on a curve but for
the sort of level of energy that we
sometimes see from Joe Biden to
certainly energized saying it is time to
finish the job the crowd chanting four
more years the reason commonly knew
greater again it was the title of the
article was on to say President Biden
appears to be residing over the kind of
manufacturing serve that Trump had
promised
folks
we're not making this stuff up
it's real
time to finish the job finish the job
[Applause]
all right so listen I I'm not going to
pretend this was the most electrifying
moment from Joe Biden but the the point
here is
um the polling looks pretty okay for Joe
Biden and there are people who are
laughing this off I got emails from
saying David Joe Biden obviously can't
win re-election it's not obvious to me
uh it's not obvious to me at all oh but
the polls the polls were spot on in
2020.
um and you know we don't need to we
don't need to do this game at this point
in time but Joe Biden certainly seems
ready and uh we're going to see Trump's
reaction we're going to see the debate
schedule we're going to see all sorts of
different things but in the midst of it
we have to talk about the latest from
Chris Christie former New Jersey
Republican Governor Chris Christie
seems to believe that he could beat
failed former president Donald Trump in
a Republican primary
foreign I'm trying to do my Tucker
Carlson laugh and I'm failing not
maniacal enough
um this is funny for a number of
different reasons now I want to be
really clear uh Chris Christie is a
better candidate than Trump and Chris
Christie the country would be way better
off with Chris Christie as president
than Donald Trump as president but this
is not what Republicans at this point in
time want and Chris Christie has no shot
at winning the Republican nomination
there's an interesting article in The
Daily Beast Chris Christie believes he
can take down Trump does anyone else
Christy told The Daily Beast I think
we'll lose if Trump's a nominee that's
why I intend to be the nominee this is
very very interesting I am the viable
Trump alternative
said Chris Christie to The Daily Beast
swiveling and promptly ending the
interview to go to work the room at the
Keen Country Club on Friday night that's
in Keene New Hampshire so you read the
article and the framing is basically
that he is going to try to appeal to
anti-trump Republicans without
ostracizing Republicans who do support
Donald Trump
okay but as the article points out what
is the math of this nonsense after
polling no higher than three percent in
any of the surveys of the prospective
2024 field so far and after finishing in
sixth place the last time he went
toe-to-toe with Trump Christy seems to
be trying to answer the question himself
before he officially jumps into the race
which is how could he be the nominee his
heart seems to want him to run but his
head doesn't sound subtle Christy seems
to be leaning toward jumping in posing
and answering questions that bolster his
ability to take down Trump like whether
he could actually be a credible
Messenger to the Maga base listen I I I
want to have one of the things about
when we have these discussions
Nikki Haley has no shot at being the
Republican nominee but I've never once
said she shouldn't run anyone who wants
to run should run it's absolutely anyone
who wants to run against Joe Biden
should run everybody should be running
sure but I'm also going to tell you that
Chris Christie has absolutely no shot he
indeed is not polling ahead of three
percent in any poll in which he appears
in some polls he's either not included
because it's just all seen as very silly
or he's polling zero and just doesn't
show up in the poll for that reason when
he left office in New Jersey he had a 15
approval so he's not even really popular
lowest of any Governor anywhere he's not
even really popular among New Jersey
constituents New Jersey Republicans I
mean it's just it's just nonsense and
you have to of course remember the
completely pathetic way in which he
humiliated himself remember back in 2016
eventually Chris Christie dropped out of
the race the Republican primary race and
endorsed Donald Trump and there was this
I mean if the Wright loves to talk about
Alpha and beta it's not really the term
those aren't the terms I really use but
if you want to apply that filter there
is it's hard to find a more beta event
than Chris Christie standing behind
Donald Trump after endorsing him and
looking like he had some bad clams on
the Jersey boardwalk just nauseous
looking uh I'll remind you of that one
of the biggest things is that everybody
is seeing happening and everybody is the
Republican party has become more Dynamic
it's become more diverse we're taken
from the Democrats we're taken from the
from the any of so many places you go to
different places
different places in the Middle East you
look at some of the airports they have
you look at the
victim systems they have and the trains
they have we're like a third world
country we're hearing some suggestions
including some from a few of your former
aides that some people inside the
Republican National
monkey wrenching with your delegates at
the state level trying to clear you away
I think you know David okay good
all right anyway so listen Chris
Christie would be my choice if you said
to me David sir the next president will
be either Trump or Chris Christie I go
with Chris Christie over Trump a
thousand times in a row New Jersey
Republican former prosecutor uh has some
understanding for decorum and how to
interact with our allies on the
international stage any day but that's
me that it's me a a voter to the left of
Joe Biden who is going to choose Chris
Christie
there is no reason whatsoever to believe
that the Republican party or any
significant fraction of it is interested
in Christie over Trump and so I welcome
anyone getting in who wants to get in
Christie's campaign would be a Dead on
Arrival and so is Nikki Haley's by the
way which we're going to talk about a
little bit later in the show make sure
you're subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
we'll be right back
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a
12-month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
pacman15 for 15 off the link is down
down below alright yesterday I told you
that President Joe Biden has announced
he will be seeking re-election in 2024
this of course did not go unnoticed by
the failed former president Donald Trump
who seeks to be his party's nominee in
2024 and would in theory face off
against Joe Biden assuming Joe Biden
wins the Democratic primary Donald Trump
massively massively triggered having a
completely insane reaction starting a
four-minute statement with many of his
typical Grievances and talking points
about Joe Biden let's look at the
beginning of this reaction then we'll
look at some key moments and uh then we
will talk about Donald Trump being
scared to debate seemingly now and
flipping out over debates being
scheduled without his approval let's
first start with the beginning of
Trump's reaction better Lighting in this
video I will admit to Joe Biden's
announcement you could take the five
worst Presidents in American history and
put them together and they would not
have done the damage Joe Biden has done
to our nation in just a few short Years
to everybody who believes that I
challenge you to present data
data not conjecture I challenge you to
present data showing the damage Joe
Biden has done not even close
thanks to Joe Biden's socialist spending
Calamity American families are being
decimated by the worst inflation in half
a century banks are failing our currency
is crashing and the dollar will soon no
longer be the world standard
which will be our greatest defeat in
over 200 years none of that is true
there's just none of it is true real
wages have been falling 24 months in a
row
in other words under Biden workers have
gotten a pay cut each and every month
for two straight years understand that
real inflation-adjusted wages
also fell during periods of Trump's
presidency it's not a completely unique
thing
we have surrendered our energy
we have not okay so I'm in a positive we
have not surrendered energy Independence
we're producing more oil than we're
exporting more oil than we imported it's
crazy what's going on here okay so Trump
just trotting out his standard lies but
then he got very apocalyptic and he
teased that Moore Biden will mean World
War III now remember Trump's been
predicting World War III if Hillary were
to have gotten elected in 2016 he's been
predicting World War III during Biden's
first term hasn't happened he's just
always predicting world war three but
then he really unleashes on Joe Biden
they say Trump was right about
everything well
I'm not predicting World War III but I
will say this we're very close and
they're only talking about nuclear
weapons on top of it all Biden is the
most corrupt president in American
history absolutely no evidence of that
and that's not even close nobody can
believe what's going on with again no
retribution whatsoever with such a
calamitous and failed presidency it is
almost inconceivable that Biden would
even think of running for re-election
you know what happened in the last
election yeah Biden won they cheated and
they rigged the election
so in all honesty my friends
does anyone really expect Trump to be
saying anything different it's been lies
about the Biden Administration from day
one it's been lies about the 2020
election from day one what else does
Trump have what can Trump Retreat to
there is nothing there and so this is
what we're going to see and by the way
continuing with the transphobia saying
children are being mutilated
our children are being indoctrinated and
mutilated by left-wing Freaks and
zealots I'm struggling to believe that
that is actually what is going on and of
course it isn't expect a lot of this and
Donald Trump is now in a tizzy
partially because a guy named Ron
DeSantis didn't rule out running against
Trump and may announce his campaign and
that infuriates Trump because it's not a
sign of loyalty and I'll be honest to
some degree the reason Trump is
triggered about Biden running again is
Biden beat him in 2020
and Trump no matter what he says
publicly knows if he beat me in 2020 he
could beat me again and the question for
Trump is given that he lost in 2020
how can he gain ground on Joe Biden in
2024 Trump's arrest and indictment May
well help him with Republican voters
it's not helping him in the general
election and so the mathematical problem
for Trump is you look at the map and you
look at the results of 2020 then you say
well you know a lot of these states
Arizona certainly hasn't moved to the
right since 2020. Wisconsin hasn't moved
to the right since 2020. Florida has but
Trump won Florida so that doesn't get
him any additional electoral votes so
Trump realizes it's a difficult map and
whether you believe Trump believes it
was stolen or not
Trump knows if you replicate 2020 in 24
it doesn't look particularly good for
Trump and so Trump is scared and the
other thing he seems scared about is
debating let's talk about that next
failed former president Donald Trump
posted an unhinged tirade to truth
social truth essential because the
Republican National Committee had I
guess the audacity to make some
decisions about primary debates without
checking with Donald Trump first this is
so damn funny New York Times reported a
couple weeks ago what was it uh yeah two
weeks ago Fox News to host first
Republican presidential primary debate
all right no big deal
the candidates will face off in August
in Milwaukee I mean think of that the
first debate is only four months away of
course the Republican National Committee
has to make some decisions about that
the article says Republican National
Committee chairwoman Ronald McDaniel
says they will be asked to agree to a
loyalty pledge before they take the
stage this is something we've talked
about before Republican candidates will
be asked to sign a pledge that if they
lose they will support whoever is the
eventual nominee we've already dealt
with that in terms of whether Trump will
go for it so I won't delve into it again
um this is happening I mean it's a
completely unremarkable thing we're
going to host the very first debate with
Fox News it will be a Fox News
Republican primary debate said Ronald
McDaniel
um Trump who's the current front-runner
has refused to say whether he would
support a nominee other than himself in
a February radio appearance he said his
support would have to depend on who the
nominee was okay so it's like no big
deal the RNC is getting themselves set
up for some debates Trump goes to truth
yesterday and says quote I see that
everybody is talking about the
Republican capital D debates but nobody
got my approval or the approval of the
Trump capital c campaign before
announcing them when you're leading by
seemingly insurmountable numbers and you
have hostile capital and networks with
angry Trump and Maga hating anchors
asking the quote questions why subject
yourself to being libeld and abused also
the capital S second capital D debate is
being held at the Reagan Library the
chairman of which is amazingly Fred Ryan
publisher of the Washington Post no so
Trump seems to be saying he will not
even participate in the first Republican
primary debate of 2024 and you know who
thinks that this is a logical thing to
do
Trump propagandist Steve Bannon Steve
Bannon appeared yesterday on the Charlie
Kirk show and said it's all a joke we're
not having a primary basically
suggesting Trump should just essentially
be given the nomination I just noticed
there's something very strange going on
with my hair and I apologize for that
um here's Steve Bannon saying Trump
should just sit out the debates we don't
have a primary and we're not going to
have our primary when President Trump I
think is just the audacity to go the
Rankin Library run by the guy that that
is the Washington post's publisher
Frederick Ryan yep
debates is is whoever the Democrat
nominee is that that's right okay so let
me interpret this for you how dare
anyone subject Trump to an opportunity
to embarrass himself which could almost
certainly only hurt him rather than help
him and to that extent I actually get it
I actually get it if DeSantis doesn't
run for let's imagine DeSantis doesn't
run if DeSantis doesn't run Trump is
essentially a shoe-in he's going to be
up against ones and twos his stock will
probably rise dramatically in the
polling
the debate can only hurt him and then if
DeSantis does run there's a risk that
the debate could hurt him now again I've
said before I don't think that the
totally uncharismatic Ron DeSantis
is going to really be able to go against
Trump in a national campaign but could
he do okay in a single debate against
Trump maybe and it's certainly possible
that if DeSantis is running that it
would not be particularly good for Trump
in that debate but also if Trump was
prepared it could be good but it is seen
as a risk to Trump and how how dare
anyone have the audacity to actually
have a primary election Trump should
just be appointed
the nominee is what Trump and Charlie
Kirk and Steve Bannon seem to believe
this is I wasn't kidding when I said
this is going to be a wild and insane
primary it's already that way and four
months from now I I know it's like it's
happening so quickly four months from
now when the debates start it's going to
be even more insane all of these clips
including Bannon on Kirk will be on our
Instagram which you can find by
searching for David Pacman show on
Instagram it'll be on Tick Tock it'll be
on Snapchat Facebook and of course
YouTube at youtube.com the davidpackman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right dozens of you sent me the
video I'm about to play and this story
and I'm going to present the story to
you as best as I understand it there is
a video that has gone completely viral
of a guy wearing an oxygen mask that
people said David this guy is an
American who faked his death he's
pretending to be Irish with an obviously
fake accent and covering his face with
an oxygen mask this is a completely
insane situation so before we play the
video I'm going to do my best to explain
to you what this is all about there's an
independent article called fugitive
accused of Faking his own death sobs as
he insists I'm an Irish orphan okay
Nicholas Rossi also known as Nicholas
alaverdian appeared on ustv claiming
mistaken identity
he is a suspected rapist said to have
faked his own death while on the run
from the FBI and living in Scotland and
he appeared on NBC's Dateline
and he was confronted and told you know
people believe you are Nicholas
oliverdian and it all completely
exploded he's 35 years old he now wears
an oxygen mask in public again it's
unclear whether it's for medical reason
or to hide his face he claims to be
Irish orphan Arthur Knight a victim of
mistaken identity who has never stepped
foot in the United States of America
last November
uh Sheriff Norman McFadden fadian ruled
that Rossi was the man U.S authorities
were seeking but he says he's just a
different person if you look at the Wiki
page about this
it says indeed Nicholas aloe Verde and
known as Nicholas Rossi and Arthur
Knight is an American sex offender who
faked his own death in 2020. so I'm
going to play the video for you here
I hope I now am getting the details
right this is a guy who says I'm an
Irish orphan
but in reality is an American who faked
his own death I believe to avoid
uh uh legal trouble okay check this this
this is I've never seen anything like
this
we were once a normal family but thanks
to the media our lives have been
interrupted and we like privacy and I
would like to go back to being a normal
husband now one of the weird things is
he I guess claims to be Irish
but I don't think that's actually an
Irish accent that sounds like sort of a
British accent which is a strange detail
for sure but then I can't because I
can't breathe I can't walk people say
that's not let me try to stand up let me
try to stand up so he tries to he I
guess tries to stand up and again it's
unclear whether the being unable to walk
is part of the disguise as well I just
don't know
sort of quote tries to stand up and the
person who's with him
um I think I think it's a woman who's
with him kind of like uh reacts like oh
no I've got to save this guy exactly
exactly what do you say to to someone
who believes that that you are Nicholas
salivary
Andrea I am not Nicholas Elementary and
I do not know how to make this clear
what do you say to people who say these
are crocodile tears he's putting on a
show this is all an act
oh thank you
and the woman on the left is treating
him like he's a crying seven-year-old
boy it's all completely Bonkers so at
some point maybe we'll know more but the
best assessment I have of this I mean
this this is a story that
it it went viral if we weren't living in
such insane times as we find ourselves
living in right now this would have gone
even more viral like without even a
shadow of a doubt this is completely
Bonkers and again I don't know if the I
think he's in a wheelchair
oxygen mask dark rimmed glasses
claiming to be Irish while speaking in a
British accent I think that that's all
part of the disguise but I have never
seen anything like this not a criminal
genius I think it's fair to say and I'm
struggling to believe that this is
actually an Irish orphan insane story
let me know what you think about it all
right there are other people running for
the 2024 Republican nomination one of
those people is Nikki Haley Nikki Haley
had an event she spoke at an event
and it was embarrassing it was low
energy rivaling Jeb Bush in 2016. it
makes Jeb Bush look electric from 2016.
and the event seems totally brain dead
and Nikki Haley's campaign continues to
remain Dead on Arrival this was the SBA
list HQ event in Virginia
and I think that means Small Business
Association list headquarters
she
for some reason to the SBA spoke about
abortion I don't know what's worse the
level of energy or the arguments that
Nikki Haley is making the next president
must find National consensus
that might sound strange to many people
under row consensus was replaced by
demonization and let's be honest most in
the media prioritize demonization
they stoked division putting pitting
Americans against each other
no one talks about finding consensus
everyone goes to the barricades and
attacks the other side
they've turned a sensitive issue that
has long divided people into a kind of
isn't this inspiring to bidding more
how many weeks are you for how many
exceptions are you for and the list goes
on
but these questions miss the point if
the goal is about saving as many lives
as possible
you don't save any lives if you can't
enact your position into law
and you can't do that unless you find
consensus
reaching consensus starts with
humanizing not demonizing
just like I have my story
I respect everyone who has their story
I don't judge someone who is pro-choice
any more than I want them to judge me
for being pro-life so she says some
things that are fine like let's not
judge each other and try to find
consensus and have compassion and
whatever else but this is just not
moving the needle and I'll tell you
where the polling is in a moment but
just just a completely whatever the
opposite of an electrifying campaign
would be that's what Nikki Haley seems
to be running she also commented about
how she feels when people decide not to
go through with a pregnancy Michael and
I struggle to have children of Our Own
I had many challenges as a teenager into
my college Years I went through numerous
surgeries
when Michael and I were married I
couldn't wait to be a mom
but what happened so easily for many of
my friends
was not my path we went through
countless sessions of fertility
treatments
every day I wake up and see or speak to
my two children I feel blessed the
greatest job I will ever have is being
their mom
our eldest daughter got married just 10
days ago
I will never forget the day she was born
and then seeing her walk down the
wedding I don't know what it is about
these speeches that Nikki Haley gives
like the These are nice touching stories
in some abstract sense so your daughter
being born your daughter's wedding day
compassion empathy but I I don't know if
it's like how the stories are written
for her and she reads that there's
something about this that couldn't
possibly be less interesting oh with her
dad
I felt what countless parents feel love
Pride overwhelming Joy
I believe every life is a blessing from
God yeah my heart hurts when someone
decides not to go through with a
pregnancy okay so in terms of how this
is going it's hard to imagine Nikki
Haley even making it to the first
primary but I guess she's going to stick
around long enough to debate if we look
at recent polling here we have an ipsos
Reuters poll where Haley is polling
three percent we have a morning consult
poll where Haley is pulling three
percent we have a big Village poll where
Haley is pulling six percent that's a B
minus rated poll so you know she's sort
of like three percent Nikki I guess is
where we are at this point in time so
listen I don't take away anything from
anybody's right and ability to run and
her desire I'm sure I guess is genuine
and unless she's auditioning for VP in
which it's sort of like a publicity tour
but I do wonder and I know I've said
this before and whenever I mention it
people in my audience seem to not be on
the same page I've asked before when
someone like Nikki Haley talks
presumably to advisors and her family
and decides to run
does she actually think to herself okay
let's see I'm pulling three percent
Trump already has 53 percent
here's my path to winning like does she
actually think she could win
or is it more of a
I think I could get some positive
attention if I do this even though I
know I'm not going to win whenever I
bring this up some people write to me
and say no David people become like
almost like delusional and they think
they could possibly win and other people
write to me and go no David of course
you understand she can't win and Chris
Christie knows he can't win and Vivek
ramaswamy knows he can't win but they
calculate that it's worth running for
some other reason I don't know the
answer but it's very difficult to
imagine how Nikki Haley could look at
the situation and think I can win and I
can win by making quite literally the
least interesting speeches in the world
about abortion to the Small Business
Association it's crazy to me let me know
what you think we're going to take a
quick break we will hear from Rhonda
McDaniel after the break we'll talk
about the Trump rape trial that has
started many many other things to
discuss stay with us we'll be back right
after this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show okay
Republican National Committee uh chair
Ronald McDaniel appeared this morning on
Fox and Friends really weird interview
it did not go well at all couple topics
were mentioned number one a new ad put
out by the RNC with AI generated footage
and secondly the topic of debates and
Donald Trump will do the first thing
first and the second thing second
although we could reverse that order but
let's not do it either way you wouldn't
really know okay no but we'll start with
the AI deep fake thing so the RNC put
out an ad
painting a picture with AI video of a
dystopian America under Biden the
footage is fake it was created by AI
it's not footage of anything that
actually took place so
Ronald McDaniel says it is not a deep
fake but it it's literally fake now deep
fake AI generated footage is fake
footage deep fake footages fake footage
we're just talking semantics here and
she with a straight face says it's AI
generated but it's not a deep fake maybe
she just doesn't even know what these
terms mean all right so let's talk about
what you guys did you immediately
responded to his rollout saying he's
going to run again he kind of said that
let me finish the job you guys rolled
this out and it's AI generated here's a
portion
border agents were overrun by a surge of
80 000 illegals yesterday evening
officials closed the city of San
Francisco
citing the escalating crime and Fentanyl
crisis so Rana essentially saying that
will happen if he gets four more years
uh what Pro can you bring us the the
mindset going into that ad
so first of all it is AI generated so
we're sharing that that up front
ethically so it's not a deep fake every
single image was AI but we are painting
a picture of a future vitamin so it's
quite literally fake now I guess what
she she seems to think that if you admit
that it's fake then it's not a deep fake
I guess like if you would if you're like
hey I'm gonna show you something fake
then it's a shallow fake or something
but then if she were to lie about it
then it would be a deep fake of course
it seems that she doesn't even really
know what these terms mean and it's it's
worth looking at the ad
because one of the unfortunate realities
of Technology advancing the way it's
advancing you know the AI generated
Trump arrest pictures which were not
real and all of these things is that the
worst instincts of the worst people
are now much more easily translatable
into a finished product that might pass
muster and when you look at the video
from that AI attack ad that the RNC put
out
you taken out of context you would have
no idea that it's fake and this is going
to be I mean we've already looked at the
the fake videos of elected officials
appearing to say things that they didn't
say this is going to be a new layer now
in political dishonesty
they showed it but do you have video of
it used to be a pretty good way of
determining whether a claim might be
true at least or is true now hey yeah I
have video of it it increasingly isn't
even going to be the evidence we need to
determine whether something did or
didn't really happen so arguably
dangerous stuff I don't believe that we
can stop it I think we need to figure
out how to work with it then the topic
of debates came up as we talked about
earlier yesterday Donald Trump flipped
out and said nobody consulted me about
doing the first debate you know whatever
in August or whatever and sort of
suggesting he might not go and Steve
Bannon saying Trump Should Skip the all
the debates all together here's Rhonda
McDaniel saying Trump doesn't
historically shy away from debates and
Brian kilometer is like well actually he
did Skip one of our debates and she's
like okay fine he did Skip One and the
entire story here for me is Ronald
McDaniel continues to lose control of
the monster that the Republican party
has created
going back to the debates can I ask you
something so the Democrats don't want uh
the top Democrats don't want a debate
with uh Joe on the stage I saw yesterday
that Donald Trump uh on true social said
I see that everybody is talking about
the Republican debates but nobody got my
approval or the approval of the campaign
uh Trump campaign before announcing them
when you're leading by seemingly
insurmountable numbers and you have
hostile networks angering with Trump and
mega hating and is asking the questions
why subject yourself to being liable and
abused so did you talk to him about the
debates is he in or is this just what he
does he he did this in 2016. working the
refs
I talked to president Trump all the time
and we've talked to all the potential
candidates we've let them know the
schedule we've announced the debates the
first debates can be with Fox Milwaukee
but every campaign and every candidate
is going to have to make a decision do I
want to participate he's going to have
to make that decision I think he'll do
it and president Trump never shies away
from a debate uh and he's very well on
debate stages
he skipped hours he skipped hours in
2016.
he did he skipped one but you know he
was on the center of the debate stage in
2016 and he never left it so we'll see
what happens but we are talking to the
campaigns and the candidates I talked to
president Trump and and Mike Pence and
and Nikki Haley were talking to all of
them all the time and we'll see what
happens what does it mean that she
talked to Mike Pence by the way Mike
Pence is Mike Pence running I don't even
know what that but that's kind of a
weird thing to interject there that is
interesting uh so the debate thing is
going to be interesting as I said
earlier if you're Trump depending on
whether DeSantis is or isn't running the
calculation as to whether you should or
shouldn't participate in debates is a
different one now 20 years ago the idea
that a presidential candidate a serious
presidential candidate polling well
would not participate in debates would
be almost unheard of but this is a
Republican party who makes excuses for
whoever it is that they want to see
elected
um when it came to Trump's taxes there
were excuses when it came to Trump's a
personal misdeeds there were excuses and
when it comes to Trump not debating
there will certainly be excuses and
there were indeed as well for the debate
that Trump skipped uh previously so this
is where we are at this point in time
Ronald McDaniel has completely lost
control of the party and one of the
things about Trump talks to me regularly
is that Trump doesn't care one way or
the other
um what Rhonda McDaniel wants Trump sees
the RNC the way he sees everyone in his
life someone that I might be able to use
to advance what's best for me or maybe
not in which case I'll just bail and say
they they were disloyal and unfair and
we will move on ultimately I think that
Trump is more likely to debate than not
to debate taking into consideration
everything that we know right now but of
course the first debate is almost four
months away and a lot can happen between
now and then so we will follow it the
Donald Trump rape trial has started a
lot to discuss here as well started
yesterday NPR has a good primer we might
call it five things to know as e Gene
Carroll's Civil Trial begins against
Donald Trump jury selection begins
Tuesday this is the defamation suit
brought against Trump by E.G and Carroll
late last year Carol accused Trump of
causing pain and suffering lasting
psychological harms loss of dignity and
invasion of her privacy Trump's lawyers
say the statute under which the assault
claim was brought against Trump violates
due process the core of this is that
Carol claims Trump raped her in the
changing room of the Bergdorf Goodman
Department Store in Manhattan in the
1990s
the suit says as a result of the pain
and suffering caused by that sexual
assault she has not been able to sustain
a romantic relationship since that day
Trump's lawyers are expected to argue
Carroll's nearly 30 year old claims
cannot be proved and that she was
motivated by potential Book Sales and
publicity
um important to know Carol has sued
Trump already twice and both matters are
still active there's the defamation suit
from November of 2019
and a November 22 suit filed under New
York's adult survivors act which opens a
one-year window when people allege
sexual assault to bring civil claims
older than those that would normally be
allowable so that is happening there are
not cameras in the courtroom there are
not cameras in the courtroom as far as I
was able to research this morning a
couple other notes the trial in
Manhattan federal court is expected to
last five to seven days reports Business
Insider and Donald Trump is not there in
person Trump said in October on Troth
Central this Miss Bergdorf Goodman case
is a complete con job it's a hoax and a
lie like all the other hoaxes that have
been played on me for the last seven
years it is unclear whether Trump will
attend any of the trial in person for
the time being Trump uh has not been
there e Gene Carroll is indeed there the
reason I bring this up is not because
anything in particular has transpired at
the trial
yet that is newsworthy or noteworthy but
because I do think it's important not to
forget that this is yet another legal
issue that is facing Trump that is in
the news whose outcome could could
impact Trump's 2024 run we'll follow it
we'll let you know what happens very
interesting new poll shows that the Maga
movement is wildly unpopular really
unpopular one of the few things less
popular than Donald Trump himself is the
Maga movement just 24 percent of
Americans surveyed have positive views
of the make America great again movement
in a new National NBC News poll this is
a very interesting poll because it
actually surveys people about a number
of other issues so for example if you
look at black lives matter
um
40 negative
38 percent positive that's a net rating
of minus two now you might say wow BLM
is really unpopular in the United States
well it's far less unpopular than
everything else in the poll Joe Biden's
net rating the Democratic party's net
rating the Republican party's net rating
are all minus 10 meaning by a 10 point
margin they are seen more negatively
than positively more unpopular than
Biden the Democratic party and the
Republican party is Donald Trump Donald
Trump has a net rating of minus 19. 34
percent positive
53 negative and then even worse than
that is the Maga movement where only 24
percent of Americans see Maga positively
and 45 negative that's minus 21 net
favorability now one of the really
interesting things strange concerning
about America things is that despite
Trump being very unpopular and Maga
being even more unpopular
Trump and his Mega movement are
currently easily the 2024 Republican
Front Runners and Trump if he becomes
the 2024 nominee
could easily win in 2024 the general
election he almost did win in 2020 even
though it was an 8 million vote margin
and a very solid popular vote win for
Joe Biden one of the biggest in fact uh
when you look at the electoral college
system that we have it didn't it would
not have taken that much of a shift in
just a handful of States three states
really uh to turn the election towards
Donald Trump now there's another
important question when you ask people
about favorability and opinions just
because moderate Republicans and
centrists for example don't like the
Maga label or everything that Maga
stands for doesn't mean they won't vote
for Trump anyway there is a huge
difference there's a canyon between I
don't like Trump and I'd vote for a
Democrat like Joe Biden those are two
very very different things Trump got 74
million votes in 2020. these were not
just the Fringe and extremists of the
Republican party we have to understand
this on the left yes naga's not
particularly well liked many Republicans
don't like Trump low favorability all of
it is true
but when you get 74 million votes it's
not just the Fringe extremists from your
party there were self-described
centrists who really didn't like Joe
Biden there were moderates there were so
on and so forth so it's very plausible
that if Trump makes the same failed
promises again I'll bring back jobs
we're gonna get two dollar a gallon gas
we're going to replace Obamacare with
something beautiful whatever promises
many of these people are going to fall
for it again even if it doesn't make a
damn bit of sense so Mega not popular
could still win in 2024. we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P here's a caller who's calling in
about my Tesla lease I'm not exactly
sure what point they want to make
hey David so I'm in the market for a
Tesla I know you're releasing soon
I'll give you 40 grand for it let me
know bye okay so I don't know what point
they're trying to make listen one of the
things I said uh a while ago when I
decided to lease a Tesla I generally
lease anyway because it provides
um tax advantages if you have a an S
corporation and uh I've explained I just
maintenance all the I explained all my
my financial reasons for going with a
lease
um in in particular with Tesla one of
the reasons I wanted to Lisa not buy was
number one a lot of the reliability data
particularly after three years is pretty
damn shaky and I want the maintenance on
a four-year-old Tesla to be someone
else's problem and not mine and I've
I've said before the range unbelievable
the charging Network fantastic better
than any other brand but build quality
very shaky uh the car's been in the shop
multiple times for the same same thing
they have it seven to ten days they
don't fix it they give me a loaner
that's been beaten to hell
um all this stuff long story short I
don't want to own a Tesla and so that's
the deal with the lease it is true that
because Tesla cut prices on these cars
multiple times
if I owned the car now it would have
lost dramatically probably I mean more
than ten thousand dollars in value maybe
even closer to 20. so that's another
reason I'm really glad that I don't own
this thing and I can just walk away from
the dramatically depreciated vehicle now
this guy wants to buy me out of my lease
for 40 Grand I don't know what the lease
buyout is at this point I haven't looked
at it but uh email me and we can talk
about it maybe I'll maybe I'll send you
my car all right a bonus show today
Bernie Sanders has endorsed Joe Biden
and is ruling out running in 2024. there
are people who wrote to me saying Bernie
had to do it why that doesn't make any
sense we'll talk about it number two
Missouri is about to force trans adults
and teens to de-transition the ACLU is
suing what on Earth is happening in
Missouri and lastly Justice John Roberts
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court is
declining an invitation from the Senate
to testify on the ethics of the Supreme
Court I am sure that Clarence Thomas's
name would come up at such a hearing
we'll talk about all of it on today's
bonus oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad David
Pacman does not have a soul he doesn't
have a soul you can make heads or tails
out of those comments if you want but I
tell you the bonus show is a good time
sign up at joinpakman.com we will see
you on the bonus check
foreign